president biden hitting the next target
in his endless inflation
blamapalooza after pointing the finger
at putin republicans and big meat
biden is also going after big oil by
sending a strongly worded letter to the
heads of seven oil companies ooh boy
threatening to use emergency powers if
they don't boost supply after bashing
them for turning a profit
comes as gas prices nationwide have
officially topped five gallons of five
dollars per gallon with no relief in
sight
and if you can't afford these sky-high
gas prices the white house says just buy
an expensive electric car
if you filled up your ev
by charging and you filled up your gas
tank with gasoline and you have the same
size tank you would save 60 per phillip
by going electric rather than using
gasoline so it's very compelling case
but again to your point we want to bring
down the price at the point of purchase
well she knows money she has stock in
electric vehicles i believe biden's
marks are so low on inflation that even
cnn is turning on him
how does prison biden's performance
right
awful i mean
i knew that was the answer but the
answer is awful i mean you know i'll
compare it to carter at this point in
his presidency right look at the
disapproval rating joe biden has on
inflation right now it's over 70
carter carter was not even there at this
point in mid 1978 when you're doing
worse than jimmy carter is doing in the
minds of americans on inflation you know
that they're holding you responsible for
the conditions that are currently on the
ground that are hurting americans in
their pocketbooks all right there's a
couple of pieces of positive news here
that we're overlooking i'm going to you
first jesse
aren't you happy for jimmy carter that
he is still alive
to see that he is no longer the worst
president in modern times this is a big
deal for him and his legacy he gets to
be here and see i'm not the bad guy yes
yes the carter renaissance i never
thought i'd ever see it in my entire
life
greg uh humor me take a trip down memory
lane shall we let's go back to
2020. when a barrel of oil was less
expensive than a slice of pizza do you
remember it went negative for a while
gas was a couple
months in that year i think it was like
less than two dollars a gallon and exxon
mobil had its worst year ever they lost
22 billion with a b dollars things
turned around demand went up price oil
went back up and now they're making
profit so joe gets freaked out because
every time the gasoline prices go up his
approval rating goes down
and he starts screaming and threatening
these oil executives and tells them to
increase supply okay how about this new
york times
biden administration cancels drilling
sales in alaska and gulf of mexico that
was in may
how's that going to help supply these
oil execs got to be thinking to myself
can you do something on permits uh can
you get the sec off our back can you can
you make those crazy radical left-wing
green lawyers stop suing us every time
we try to start a project or how about
helping us out building a refinery we
haven't built a major one since the
1970s so he's panicking
and you saw this coming because he ran
on getting rid of fossil fuels that was
a direct quote we'll get rid of him
we'll phase him out and then he gets
into the oval and he does everything to
do that through lawsuits and regulations
but now
they think he's basically like the
undertaker for the fossil fuel industry
right they're going to put you out of
business if you're ahead of one of these
companies and then he starts freaking
out because he's going to lose the
midterms and possibly the next election
and now he's like drill baby drill
joe biden has turned into sarah palin
he's getting that desperate and now he's
threatening to confiscate their prophets
like some third world dictator this is
not how the president in the united
states should be acting this is not a
coherent energy policy yeah he seems to
be reaping what he sowed is that the
phrase thank you very much dana i i do
think though again the good news because
i read your book it's like what happened
after carter we we had
eight years the reagan revolution so if
this is carter 2.0 aren't we due
for something really big perhaps well
yes i mean this is really bad and also
it's also the refining capacity right so
it's not just getting the oil out of the
ground there's a lot of reasons we don't
have enough refining capacity including
a lot of places a lot of those were shut
down during coven they need constant
maintenance and they're under the threat
of regulation constantly so why would
you invest in more refining um
capacity so even if it goes to saudi
arabia let's say they're like okay fine
we'll drill a few more holes you can't
refine it so there's a problem there the
other thing that i just can't stand the
pr stunt of sending a letter
it's like the most weak thing that you
can do and the media ran with it there
were headlines everywhere that biden is
going to send a letter today like who
cares plus then he asks the secretary of
energy grand home that you just saw
there who has stock in the eevee
industry
he has asked her to convene an emergency
meeting on the issue
now
they're always so right
yeah i wonder if i wonder if biden wrote
wrote the letter put in the envelope
stamp and then clipped it onto the
mailbox for the mailman to pick up the
red flag yes that's what my mother used
to do although what is with like how do
you feel about all the finger pointing
you know that one at one one side
they're blaming you know they're saying
this is important to transition
americans off evil fossil fuels and then
you blame putin for it so it can't be a
good thing if you're blaming everyone i
i agree with you and i i just
parenthetically a couple of notes i i am
delighted that the ev revolution is
getting a push by the shortage in the
fossil fuel uh sector so i i i think we
all will transition to ev
eventually i deplore the fact that the
president's going to go to saudi arabia
and be and who are himself excuse my
language to the saudis
attempting to get them to increase
production i think it's really unseemly
a letter what the hell is a letter where
is the energy to do something
substantive uh to your point rather than
the silly writing a letter
the one
place where i suspect that we differ is
you are giving big oil
a green light
or a free pass
there is no doubt but that the average
net profit margin for oil and gas
production in the fourth quarter of 2021
was 31.3 percent that's the average net
profit 31.3 percent exxon made 5.5
billion chevron 6.3 billion conoco 5.8
billion big oil is reaping
the windfall when the rest of us have to
pay at the point aren't you invested in
big oil geraldo i do not believe i am
yes you are well done i i haven't
checked but okay of course so you're
reaping the windfall too
hmm i i am not i do not concede that
point i am not speaking personally i'll
concede i am uh i drive a car that gets
12 miles to the gallon exactly really
what kind of car might that be
you mentioned it
does it rhyme with bentley
so judge last word to you care to
respond to geraldo i think i think first
of all when you say he's whoring himself
to the saudis it's really prostituting
himself
but i think the issue is bigger than all
than what we're talking about with the
specifics
the administration is
not only unfeeling
not only demanding that we suffer more
but they're lying to us and they lie to
us every day and they don't feel the
pain
that senior citizens are are paying are
feeling and so many americans are
feeling every one of us here at this
table is gainfully employed okay
we don't have any idea what's going on
in middle america with people who have
to make a decision as to whether they're
going to drive to work or drive to the
doctor's office and this administration
is lying
he gets up uh biden he says there's no
question putin is principally
responsible for the intense financial
pain that american people and families
are are bearing that's a lie mr
president and you know it because we
know that we get 51 of our petroleum our
gas and oil from canada 8 from mexico
and it was 8 from russia before we
started cutting back because of what's
happening in ukraine so to blame
everything on russia and so we got all
of our gas from them in the first place
is an outright lie and they're corrupt
too jennifer granholm okay she violated
the stock disclosure law
nine times and she has exercised 1.6
million dollars in stock options in
electric cars these people are conning
us they don't feel our pain they're
giving us a run around with a letter to
the to the to the oil industry
yeah and the meeting there's no question
last month biden canceled one of the
most high-profile oil and gas lease
sales pending before the department of
interior they don't care about us all
they care about is stuffing their own
pockets and the rest of us well be
damned with you i just i don't think
it's about money i think it's the fact
that he's not steering this ship
these decisions are like from young woke
staffers who hate fossil fuels
it's really they don't care that we're
being punished i don't think it's about
greed it's just pure controversy we
can't afford it you can't buy green
electric cars
contempt over greed i think it is
contempt i think i think it's yeah it's
contempt for our society in general and
it disgusts me by the way i'm a man of
the people i went and ate at the outback
last week judge yeah good it was
difficult what'd you have a baked potato
and a steak and some creamed spinach
wine selection
coming up another huge night for
republicans and the biggest sign yet
that democrats could be in for a
beatdown hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now